[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining me today.
My name is Vidya Nagarajan.
And I'm a senior product
manager at Google working
on the Chrome and Android team.
In today's session
this afternoon,
we'll be discussing how to
make every screen work for you,
whether it's managing a
distributed workforce,
delighting your customers,
or transforming your business
in this truly digital world.
But first I spent my formative
years in this tiny country
in the Middle East
called Kuwait.
And growing up, I
grew up in a household
where both my parents worked.
And I vividly
remember my childhood
where I used to visit
my mother's workspace.
And I used to be fascinated
seeing these amazing collection
of floppy disks and pens
and papers and typewriters.
And it used to just
completely amaze me,
seeing all these desk
phones out there.
And my mom used to type these
documents electronically.
And then she would
print them ahead of time
to be reviewed during
meetings on paper.
Fast forward to today, whenever
my mom visits my workspace
today, she thinks things are
quite different, of course.
Of course, there are
a lot more screens.
You no longer have desk phones.
Desk phones are
replaced by smartphones.
You have laptops.
And of course, you have
video conferencing devices.
So imagine a workplace
where every employee
is completely empowered.
Every employee has
appropriate access to data.
They have appropriate
access to technology,
so that they can be connected.
They can collaborate
with each other more.
They can help the enterprise
accomplish their top goals,
the organizational goals.
They can ship products much
faster, quality products that
delight their
customers, and overall
increase the
organization's bottom line.
However the reality
is much starker,
if you actually look at
the world labor stats,
there are over 3.25
billion workers today.
However there are
only 750 million PCs
in business and 300 million
managed smartphones.
So the face of the
workforce is also
changing drastically today.
This is the world of
the new generation,
the next generation, the
generation of the millennials.
In this generation,
they are really
born with a smartphone,
a mobile phone in hand.
My daughters are
constantly on their phone.
And they use this
phone to do everything.
It's not just about talking
to their friends and SMSing.
It's also about
having a lifeline
and maintaining a connection
with your friends and family.
And it's the same workforce.
It's the same new
generation who is
going to be in your workforce.
And they are going to also be
using these phones to do work.
So a typical day
in my life actually
starts with me dropping
my daughters in school.
And then I would do a
myriad of other activities
in between, before I
actually end my day.
And the activities
would range from,
I would stop at the gas
station to get some gas.
I would ride the elevator to
take the floors in my building.
I would grab some lunch.
I would probably visit
the dentist office.
I would work at my desk.
I would network
with my colleagues.
I would shop for groceries
in my nearby Safeway store.
I would stop by the
mall for some shoes,
take a taxi to the
airport, catch a flight,
and check in, maybe going
to a conference in Vegas
if I'm not at Next.
And then I would
probably go at it
at the casino when
I have the time.
So what is one thing that is
common in all these scenarios?
What do you see that's really
Please don't look at the notes.
What is common in
these scenarios?
AUDIENCE: Screens.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN:
It's the screens.
So there are screens everywhere.
And that's the huge opportunity.
So we are all surrounded
by screens everywhere.
Screens are becoming ubiquitous.
So we are truly in the midst
of a cultural revolution that
is being completely
driven by technology.
And much of this technology
to fuel this revolution
exists today.
But it's just super expensive.
It's not mainstream, because
it's super expensive.
There are
manageability concerns.
There are concerns with energy.
However as we make more
technological innovations
with display, hardware
innovation, sensor innovations,
innovations with Bluetooth Low
Energy, using energy efficient,
environmentally
sensitive materials,
you will find that these
screens truly become ubiquitous.
They're going to be everywhere.
So every stop sign out
there in my traffic light
will also be a digital sign.
So this is an example
that I always love to use.
So I'm major art connoisseur.
I collect a lot of art.
And I always keep
saying, how amazing
would it be that
if I were to buy
an artwork from my
an museum that's
no longer going to be a scroll
of paper that I take home?
But instead, it's going
to be a digital sign.
It's going to be
a high resolution
thin, flexible
display, which shows
a new masterpiece every month.
And it has a subscription.
It comes with a
monthly subscription
that I pay for, so super simple.
So our mission at Google is
to transform organizations
by expanding the
use of computing.
And we believe we are
well-positioned to do that
with the Chrome and the
Android operating systems
and various solutions
that are built around it.
So for example, just looking
at the retail vertical,
we see lots of use
cases that are stemming
with single purpose
use cases that
can connect the
entire supply chain
from the front of the
store, all the way
to the back of the store.
So here you have employee
devices, shared employee
devices in the back office.
You have customer-facing kiosks.
You have digital signs
in the store front.
You have data capture
handheld devices
in an operational warehouse.
And then you also have
a moving sales associate
who is walking around
with an Android tablet.
And then lastly, one
of the biggest pet
peeves for me is when I
walk to a retail store,
you have these amazingly
long waiting lines.
So this can be amazing,
if I can actually
have a sales associate
who can walk up
and can use a mobile
point of sale system
and can automatically
check me out.
So there, I have a very
seamless shopping experience.
So again taking retail
as an example here,
we find that a lot
of retailers are
trying to connect the online
as well as the physical store
presence.
And to do that, they
are accomplishing
this in a number of ways.
They are implementing
a range of solutions,
which are fraught with
their own problems.
So on the left hand
side, you see a situation
wherein you have
an engineer who is
standing on top of a ladder
in front of a broken sign.
And he's actually resorting
to manual intervention.
He's probably going
to reboot the device
to bring that system back on.
So the fundamental
problem here is
that there is going to
be a lot of downtime,
because the signs are down.
And in addition, it's
also very expensive,
actually bringing a technician
out there to fix the problem.
And then on the other hand,
you have the classic problem,
where a lot of retailers just
choose to go the old school way
and just have static signs.
Everything is paper based.
This results in also very
static and very expensive,
because now you're going
to have printing costs.
You're going to
have to hire people
who will have to hang up these
signs, replace these signs.
And you can't do any kind
of modern, event-triggered
marketing or
notifications around it.
So we believe Chrome OS and
Android are the best device
platforms for providing
truly engaging experiences.
So Chrome OS is an extremely
reliable operating system.
It provides an
appliance-like uptime.
It's extremely secure.
And we have designed
Chrome OS from the ground
up with security in mind.
We offer Chrome OS secure
updates, verified boot process
isolation, devices--
the nice thing is, the OS
updates are common and get
consistently applied across
every device form factor
that Chrome OS provides
or that Chrome OS runs on.
This results in an extremely
low total cost of ownership.
And lastly the platform
is very flexible.
You can easily support and
run any type of HTML5 app that
has been designed for the web.
And it also provides a broad
support for peripherals.
So Android also, security
is our number one priority.
And Android ships secure,
with on-device protection.
It offers multiple layers
of ongoing protection
through cloud based services.
We use machine learning as
well as event correlation
to detect and to make our
security systems really strong
and smarter over time.
So with the Android
and Chrome OS,
we can now have power literally
any type of form factor
out there, starting with
devices with screens.
So you have smartphones,
tablets, laptops,
all the way to devices without
screens, so whether it's a box
or it's a stick.
And this helps you
promote use cases,
like smart digital signage,
all the way extending up
to innovations in the
Internet of Things with IOT,
even with Android things.
So we're announcing
two new devices today.
And these devices have
been manufactured by AOPEN.
It's called the AOPEN Chromebox
Mini and the AOPEN Chromebase
Mini.
So the device here you see
is called the AOPEN Chromebox
Mini.
This device can be paired.
It's a rugged device.
It can be paired with
any screen out there
and can truly transform it
into a smart digital sign.
In addition, these are the
AOPEN Chromebase Minis.
And these devices
can be used to power
any kind of high traffic zones.
So they can be there.
It's a 10 inch tablet, 10 inch
tablet type of form factor.
It has touch support.
And these are good examples of
actually apps that are running.
So it's actually off right now.
But let's come back to it.
But these two devices
are also devices that
will be running Android apps.
And we announced that as well.
I'll talk about that
in a little bit.
But we will be
supporting Android apps,
starting with Chrome
milestone 57 in Kiosk mode.
And we'll quickly show
you a demo of the two apps
that we have running pulled
down from Google Play.
So as an organization,
when you are looking
to transform your
workplace, so there
are some factors that you need
to consider when you are making
the decision, in terms
of what type of use cases
you want to support and
what type of solutions
you want to deploy.
So the first form factor--
first important factor that
you might want to consider
is first of all, really
identify what problem
you're trying to solve.
So if the problem that
you're trying to solve
is you want to have a completely
bolted down device that
is stationary that is
not going to move around,
the device that is probably of
the right form factor for you
is probably a Chromebase.
It's a device of this kind.
On the other hand, if
it's a device where
you have a moving salesperson
or a moving associate who
is walking around the store
and is trying to help customers
in the store finding
products on the shelf,
the device probably
is an Android tablet.
There are also
various price points
that can become applicable.
And price becomes a
really important criterion
when you're defining
what type of solution
does choose and deploy.
So here for example,
if you want to consider
indoor signage where you want
to have-- where ruggedness
does not matter.
Temperature sensitivity
In that case, you could probably
consider a low cost Chromebit,
which costs as low as $89.
So this can be a good
solution to quickly
get to internal corporate
dashboards up and running.
On the other hand, if you need
to have a device that works
and powers your outdoor
signage that can
even power your billboards, you
probably want a rugged device.
So any one of the
AOPEN Chromeboxes
could actually
help you with that.
Similarly, if you
have a warehouse,
and you have employees
working in the warehouse who
need to have rugged hand-held
devices as data capture
devices, the Honeywell
device or the Zebra device
are probably right
devices that you may
want to select and consider.
Chrome OS also offers a
variety of different solutions
that we have built,
building on top
of both the Chrome and
the Android platforms.
However at Google, we have
been building solutions
around the Chrome platform.
The three specific solutions
that we have been building
are public sessions,
digital signage,
and single purpose kiosks, which
I will talk about in a bit.
So first to describe
each of these three use
cases, one, digital signs.
So I'll walk through
all these three examples
also in terms of a retail
setting and how this works.
So consider again,
you're a retailer.
And you have Mary who is
your most loyal shopper, who
has walked into your store.
And your store is completely
outfitted with digital signs,
smart digital signs which are
showing promotional content
prices and a lot of
promotional information, which
keep changing with
the time of the day.
So now the intelligence
sign recognizes Mary.
And it identifies
her as a woman.
And she's about, say,
30, 35 years old.
And then as Mary continues
to walk through the store,
it's providing her
with the right content,
relevant content, or
maybe access to coupons,
or access to other type
of promotional links
that she can take advantage of,
which makes her entire shopping
experience to be truly
personalized and delightful.
So how does this all work?
We promote this kind of a
solution using Chrome OS
devices.
So you can actually pair
a screen, a monitor,
with a Chromebox.
And you can get a smart screen.
And Chrome OS inherently
supports beacon technology
from Google, which is
called the Eddystone Beacon.
So it comes in with
a built in sensor.
And with Eddystone
Beacons, the way it works
is the screen would now
broadcast Eddystone URLs.
And any user-- in
this case Mary--
when she's walking
around and walking about
to sign her smartphone
picks it up.
And then she receives
notifications in her smartphone
where she can actually
click the appropriate links
to access coupons or
promotional content
or anything of that sort.
So all of this is technology
that is possible today.
In addition, when
I spoke earlier
that the smart sign is able to
recognize Mary and determine
that she's a woman,
and she's probably
about 30 to 35 years old, that
is possible using integrations
with the Cloud Vision API.
So you can integrate with
the Cloud Vision API.
And that can detect
even if Mary--
it can detect her emotions.
It can detect her moods.
It could say, Mary is probably
not very happy right now.
Or Mary is sad.
And based on what
her moods are, it
can also provide relevant
contextual information
that gets passed on
to her smartphone.
The second most
important solution
that we have been building
is called a single app kiosk.
And again in this case, Mary
now has identified the items
that she wants to purchase.
And she can go and
check them out.
So she can use a Chromebase
to actually go and check out
the items.
It could be a self-service
check out kiosk.
Or it could be a
kiosk where she's been
assisted by a sales associate.
And lastly in the
final scenario,
this is a situation where
at the time of checking out,
Mary is asked if she wants
to sign up for a credit card.
How many of you, when you go
to a store, have been asked,
do you want to sign
up for a credit card?
Or do you want to sign
up for a line of credit
from this retailer?
It's a very common scenario.
So here Mary is
asked to do that.
And she says, yes.
She wants to do it.
So she can actually
use this session.
It's called Public sessions.
We have built this on Chrome OS.
And with Public
sessions, Mary does not
have to sign in with
a Google account.
In fact, she doesn't have
to sign up with any account.
She just gets into the session.
It's completely private,
completely secure,
completely incognito.
And within this
session, she can quickly
fill out the application.
And then she's done.
And once she exits the session,
all data on the session
is completely removed.
The session is ephemeral.
Any data in the device
is completely removed
and wiped out, making this to
be a truly incognito session.
So as your deployment scales,
you start with one device.
And now you want to scale
out to hundreds of devices
or even thousands of
devices and also want
to scale out to many
geographic locations.
You may want to be able
to manage these devices.
As I mentioned in
the earlier scenario,
you wouldn't want to have
a situation where you're
sending out a technician or an
engineer to every remote site
and have that technician
fix the problems.
But instead you would probably
want to remotely manage
your devices.
You want to remotely
manage your policies
and push the configurations
through a Remote Management
Console.
So Google offers a web-based
Remote Management Console
to manage your
Chrome OS endpoints.
And it's called the Chrome
Device Management Console.
And with the Chrome
Device Management Console,
you can do a ton
of stuff really.
So you can monitor the
health of the devices.
As an IT administrator,
you can push policies.
You can detect
connectivity status,
which devices are online,
which devices are offline.
You can also get to
remote screen grabs.
You can schedule automatic
restarts and reboots.
We'll go through a quick
demo towards the end, where
you can see some of these,
some of this functionality
in action.
And similar options also
exist with Android devices
that need to be managed.
And we work with a number of
third party partners like SOTI,
and MobileIron, and AirWatch,
who definitely provide
similar offerings as well.
And the most important
thing, and the advantage
of the Chrome and the
Android platform ecosystem,
is the robust app ecosystem
that is out there.
So you have a ton of
applications out there.
So first of all, you have
access to over 1 million apps
on Google Play.
You also get access to several
Chrome content management apps.
So you have apps like SCALAR,
Wondersign, Appspace, Skykit.
All of these are rich
HTML5 content apps
that can be deployed on a Chrome
media player, on a Chromebox.
And you can actually convert
that into a digital sign.
You can transform it
into a digital sign.
And today I'm also really
happy to announce the support
for Android Kiosk apps.
So you can actually
run Android Kiosk apps
on any one of our list
of supported devices
where Android apps
are enabled today.
We've got about four
devices out there.
In addition, these
two devices out here
are our hero devices for
purpose bolt, the Chromebox Mini
and the Chromebase Mini.
These two devices will also
support Android Kiosk apps.
So with this, you can actually
get a fully locked down,
immersive experience.
You can use the same Chrome
Device Management Console
to push down Chrome apps.
And you can also push down
the Android apps from Play.
So here is an example.
We worked with a
retailer, with a partner
in Australia called CrowdDJ.
And they have a very
cool Android app that
is available in Google Play.
And this app actually allows
customers to control the beat.
They allow customers to
select the tracks from Spotify
that they want their customers
in gyms or in event venues
or in restaurants to
actually have access to.
So we can actually
now run this app.
This is the Android app that
is downloaded from Play.
And it runs on this device,
on the Chromebase Mini.
So they actually
have this piloting
in a bunch of
centers in Australia.
Similarly education,
one of the biggest use
cases for Kiosk apps is
running assessments, testing
applications in schools.
And with this functionality,
a lot of schools
can actually deploy
Android-based testing
applications, which
can then be locked down
to the device to create a
full immersive experience.
So I wanted to go
through a quick demo of--
maybe we can do a quick demo
here of turning off the device,
so that you can actually
see how the app looks like.
So we have two devices.
Oh, it actually runs.
So in this one
device, we're actually
running the IMDB application.
So the IMDB app has been
downloaded from Google Play.
It's installed in the device.
So we use the Chrome
Device Management Console.
Push the app.
And then once the
app is pushed down,
the app instantly
runs on the device.
It can be done remotely.
And now you have this app
acting as my video kiosk.
So I can pretty
much run any video.
Hopefully the network is good.
But you get the idea.
So it does run.
I'm going to skip the ad.
But this is a completely locked
down, immersive experience.
So it's locked down.
And it's running an Android app.
The second example is we
selected an app, which
is used by the Hyatt Hotels.
So it's a Hyatt Regency app.
It's used in their rooms.
It's an in-room
controller app, so
that every guest who is
in the hotel premises,
they have this device that is
sitting by their bed stand.
And they can actually
access assets and properties
of the hotel.
And this is, again, an Android
app that is just downloaded
and now running on this
Chromebase, Chrome OS device.
So these are two good examples.
And you can do the same thing
with the Chromebox Mini.
You can pretty much power
this with any big display.
It could be a display
of this, a huge display.
And you can then run
Android apps as well.
So that's our goal.
And lastly deployment
is a huge consideration
when you're selecting any of
these different solutions,
whether it's Chrome or Android.
With Chrome, we have really
made the deployment process
to be fairly simple.
So it's really as simple
as getting a Chromebox,
connecting it to a
screen, whether it's
an HDMI port or a display port,
opening up the Chrome Device
Management Console on a laptop,
configuring the policies,
pushing it down.
And then really you
have a digital sign.
So the app is already
pushed onto the device.
And then you have
content that is changing.
And it's reflecting based
on who the audience is.
In addition today
we're also announcing
support for Chrome Kiosk API.
So these APIs would really
allow third party partners
to build custom solutions on
top of the Chrome Management
Console.
So you can now access
specific Chrome policies
to control things like
reboots or remote commands.
So this is something that
we also have available.
And lastly, last but
not the least, this
is not the most exciting
feature is actually.
One of the most
common feedback we
get from our partners
and our customers
is that the process of signing
up and purchasing a Chrome
Kiosk is very complicated today.
You have to do a complex
mechanism of domain
registration, verification.
You don't own the domain.
You're not an IT administrator.
You don't own the DNS
records for the domain.
So it's a very
complicated process.
So our goal is we want to
make the process for anybody,
whether it's a mom and pop
shop, a flower shop owner,
or it's a small team
within a huge enterprise,
to be able to very easily
sign up for a Chrome Kiosk.
So these should just
provide three fields.
They need to provide their
name, their email address,
and their phone number.
So once they provide
these three fields,
they will automatically be
able to, with a quick email
verification and
SMS verification,
they will be able to instantly
access a web-based console.
And then two trial licenses
will be given to them so
that they can manage devices.
And they can then purchase more.
So we'll do a demo
of this as well.
And Raj, do you want to
help me with the demo?
RAJ DURAISMY: Hey everybody.
My name is Raj Duraismy.
I'm a product manager.
I'm a part of Chrome
operating system team.
So I'm just going to really
quickly show our really
simple, we-based sign up.
So one of the common feedback
that we always get is hey,
I really want to
try Chrome Kiosks.
I want to just put a
couple of digital signs
in my retail store.
But the thing is,
it's really complex.
I have to pay a license fee.
I'm not even sure how to
do this kind of stuff.
So what we are seeing here is a
simple web-based sign up form.
Just go to this URL.
We are going to open it up
by the end of this month.
Just enter a bunch of
details like your name,
your email address,
your phone number,
what's your business name,
and what kind of domain
you want to secure.
It's as simple as this.
And you can go ahead
and say, yes, accepting
and create your account.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: So here
for example, Raj entered it.
I got an email address.
I got an email from him that
said welcome to the Chrome
Kiosk trial.
And I can sign up for it right.
I then go and follow the steps.
I click Accept.
And at that point--
RAJ DURAISMY: So once
you get the email,
once you verify that you
are the rightful owner
for this particular
account, you will also
be asked to verify your phone
number as a second factor
authentication.
And once you do that, you
will immediately get access
to our admin console.
We are very happy to announce
that all online sign-ups are
going to get two free
licenses for 30 days.
So you will get access to
our Google Admin console.
You can go to Device
Management, with the credentials
with which you signed up for.
You will be able to
enroll any Chrome devices,
whether it be Chromebase Mini,
whether it be Chromebox Mini
or any other Chrome device.
You can just enroll your device
to this particular account.
And I'm just going
to show a quick demo
of how the things work.
So you go to Device Settings.
And there is a setting
called Kiosk Settings.
And there are, as
we just said, there
are multiple partners
who have published
Chrome applications and also
Android applications that
can run in Kiosk mode.
I'm going to select an app
from one of our partners.
They are called Appspace.
They do a lot of
corporate communications
related to digital signs.
So you can just add their app.
You can just save it again.
And then you say,
OK, I want to auto
launch this particular
application.
Just say yes, I want to
enable health monitoring.
I want to enable to
device log upload.
Yes, I have notified my users.
And that's all about it.
In a matter of less than
five minutes, as you saw now,
you'll be able to get
your digital signs up
and running in one
of your retail stores
or in one of your office spaces.
And just briefly, you
will be-- it's not just
configuring the app
and pushing the app.
There are a few things like,
yes, you'll be able to monitor
whether the your
device is online.
You'll be able to
remotely troubleshoot.
You'll be able to remotely
reboot the machines.
You will be able to push down
the network configuration.
You can say, hey,
I want my devices
to connect this network alone.
And you can even
enforce policies.
Like if someone is going
to steal the device,
let's say, you're showing the
device outside your store.
You can say nobody
will be able to use it.
You can do a bunch of good
stuff with our Chrome Device
Management.
And of course, what
I highlighted today
is only a minimal
set of policies.
We have so many
levers here with which
you'll be able to control
your deployment very easily.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]